so enemy is directed by the man who made
prisoners which was my favorite film of
last year thus I am extremely excited to
tell you guys what I think about this
one enemy is directed by Denis
Villeneuve I'm a dumb American and I'm
trying guys as I said in my intro this
comes from the director of prisoners and
this movie also stars Jake Gyllenhaal
although this movie was actually made
directly before prisoners it's a much
smaller film it's about a man who's a
history teacher Jake Gyllenhaal and one
day a co-worker recommends that he
watches this movie so he rents it and as
he's watching this movie he is convinced
that one of the actors in the film looks
exactly like him in fact he does it's
his exact look-alike so he sets out on
this journey to try to find this man and
figure out exactly who he is
figure out what this guy is doing
because I mean it is Jake Gyllenhaal
playing both characters so the
resemblance is obviously uncanny and
this starts him on a path of
psychological tension surreal dreamlike
imagery and a really great movie before
I go any farther I should say that enemy
is not your stereotypical type film this
is not a film that follows your
traditional linear structure of
filmmaking it has absolutely nothing
traditional about it if you walk into
this movie expecting a beginning and a
middle and end and everything to be all
cohesive and understandable on that
first viewing you're going to be
disappointed because this is the type of
movie that as soon as it ends you're
like okay I need to research this now I
need to go online and see what other
people are saying and do listen to
people's theories I need to figure out
what was going on at this certain scene
I want to talk about this movie and
that's exactly the type of movie that I
love a movie the promotes discussion
amongst film nerds you know where after
you see it you're like oh my gosh what
did you think of that scene what do you
think that means
what do you think that means because
everyone I've talked to after seeing
this movie has had the exact same type
of reaction where they just want to know
my interpretation of something that's
the type movie this is and I think it's
a very good thing this is an excellent
looking movie it is shot beautifully the
score for this film was fantastic it was
so eerie and subdued but then there were
times where just exploded and it really
helped this movie as well to be this
sort of Hitchcockian dreamlike almost
sort of like vertigo
in a way if I were to compare this to
another film I would say it's kind of
like only God forgives combined with
vertigo except vertigo was a little more
traditional straightforward storytelling
only God forgives had way more violence
in this movie has but it has only God
forgives sort of dreamlike quality to it
and Vertigo's tension that all wrapped
up into one really feels like enemy Jake
Gyllenhaal's terrific in this movie he
really did such a great job playing both
roles because you really started to be
like what is this like you have ideas as
the movie rolls along you can kind of
start to connect things it's not a movie
that has like a giant revelation where
you're like oh you know what I mean I
didn't want it to be like that either
because I didn't want some big stupid
twist I didn't want some big moment
where like yeah I saw that coming a
million miles away as the movie
progresses you are slowly able to figure
out what is going on and as that starts
to happen it really started to affect me
I really started to get more frightened
and more disturbed by this guy's plight
because the way the film was made was so
disturbingly haunting at time certain
imagery that was in this movie involving
spiders really freaked me out and I'm
telling you this movie has something
about it that I think is going to be
discussed for many years I can't quite
say this is the next this or this is the
next that all I'm saying is that enemy
is a film that people are going to be
talking about after they see it it's a
very impressive movie it's beautifully
shot it's wonderfully acted and it has
such a small story but as that story
starts to grow and expand you really
really get invested in what this guy is
doing but like I said not a traditional
movie so don't walk into this movie
expecting one this is actually going to
be my next analyzed review because I
really want to delve deep into this
movie but I'm going to wait until after
it's released so more people can see it
because there's no way that I want to
spoil some of the things that happen in
this movie my only issues with the film
are that due to the fact that it is so
different and a little bit hard to grasp
at times I think sometimes that takes
away from the enjoyment of the movie
nevertheless enemy is a film that I
think you should see especially if you
are film lover or someone who wants to
learn about directing or writing or
acting this is a very interesting movie
and I
can't wait to see what else denis
villeneuve I'm trying does I'm going to
give enemy an a I think it's the best
film I've seen so far in 2014 and I'm
pretty sure it's going to be on my list
towards the end of this year guys thanks
so much for watching I'm looking forward
to when more people can see this movie
and talk about it and when you guys can
see it as always if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck myn
eyes